well going back to the someone to watch
award how much pressure did you feel
after that because I'm sure it's a great
feeling to layton but then there's also
this this new pressure that I've got to
follow up with something wonderful and
and socio gee it's funny because I
remember we were in negotiations with
David for the rights when I won that so
it was strange because it was all these
pressing reasons like what are you doing
that to someone to watch what are you
doing and I couldn't talk about it yet
because that's I think it was just super
would have been I would have loved to
have but it would've been almost preempt
it woulda been way too pre-emptive you
know until something signed I feel like
it's not it's not respectful to talk
about it but everywhere at the time
feeling like it felt good because I had
this dream thing like at the timing felt
so I felt that was probably like one of
the high moments of like my life like I
had this I won this award which is
surreal and they did great for me it
helped it was that I use that money to
pay for the option which I would never
been able to afford on my own otherwise
and then I had my next thing and in some
ways that was a mistake and not a
mistake like what for me that what it
was I went okay i have my next thing and
this is what I gonna make and because
this was David and he gave me the rights
and it was a one smell like a low
instant lifetime thing probably possibly
for him and definitely for me I was
totally willing and ready to put all my
eggs in that basket but the life lesson
not that I've learned because that
implies I did something wrong but the
life lesson I've gained from it is that
the independent film industry is just
too fickle to have only one thing going
on you know it's too I tried to generate
another project and I got really close
to happening but ultimately my heart was
always still in co ji like I couldn't oh
I couldn't let go of that and I'm glad I
did that but I also know now moving
forward that I've got to have like four
things I've got to have it five figs you
know it's almost not fair to that
project to to put that much of yourself
into it until it's really ready to go
because there's so many other elements
have nothing to do with you nothing to
do with your persistence or passion or
ambition it just has everything to do
with literally people's schedules and
money and how cheaply can something be
made or not and there's so many other
things in place and then you almost put
too much it's kind of when you're in a
relationship with someone you can't
expect them to deliver all of your
happiness you kind of need to find it
yourself and and I sort of expected co
ji deliver
my happiest so I kind of went through
this really dark period where no one
wanted to make it and it was kind of
like crying I understand why they don't
want to make it it's a darker film it
doesn't wear sedaris his voice on its
sleeve there's no voiceover in it that's
not it's funny I think it's funny but
it's also got this whole other angle to
it that's challenging and devices and
and all of these things and that's what
I wanted it to be so I didn't want to
relent on that so and I didn't want to
relent on some of my creative control
over the project so it just took longer
to get made but I don't think it would
have been is emotionally difficult for
me had I um diversified myself more you
know so one of my goals now like in life
is to just sort of like I've got
something that hopefully is going to go
this summer I can't talk it same thing I
can't talk about it yeah but it's a
really exciting project if I would I
could not be happier that goes the
summer but at the same time like I'm
reading a lot of scripts i'm reading a
lot of books like I'm trying to find
something to do next trying to find
material you know to get excited about
in the meantime so that I'm not throwing
all of my energy into that one thing do
you thrive on that sort of that unknown
area because it's like it's exciting
it's also scary at the same time is that
yeah I always said like every time I
open up a script because I'd love to
make something I that I haven't written
you know that someone else wrote I was
there when I open a script I like I
always loved the first page no matter
what you know I mean I want to love it
like I I start out loving it and then
usually it's like my page 10 I'm like
okay I'm not gonna you know that's what
I've only ever I mean I read so many
scripts not to say that people are
sending them to me but the agency sends
them to me and I read so many and I
think in the three years I've had agents
I've only ever gone in like three times
how'd it may be hundreds of script you
know it's like cuz you want to want to
love it and it's and it's hard to find
that match I think that's why I
ultimately will end up writing more
writing and directing more than an just
direct but when you do find that match
that it's a David Fincher talked about
it he was like when you read a script
and you love it and you want to make it
that first feeling you have is what you
always have to hold on but this isn't
direct quote but you always have to hold
on to that because the process of
getting the film made is everyone's
stripping away from what you initially
loved about it you know and so the way
to keep the film true to what your
intentions were to try to just remember
that first like spark you had the first
thing you really loved about it and see
oh geez definitely like a test
to that like I had there are three or
four moments three or four scenes that I
knew I always wanted to be realized that
sort of what kept me going and so I use
those as like the cornerstones you know
I always said even when it comes down
because we had to make the movie weight
cheaper than it had been initially
budgeted or written to be and he kind of
go okay well these are the moments that
have to deliver these are the moments we
need a half a day tissue not just a
quarter day or these are the moments or
hey the locations got to be better
because it's got to look like that you
know where you have to fight to make
sure those things stay true great did
you someone like the adventure can have
the time and money to make sure every
moment stays true to that but an
independent film you're just like you
gotta you gotta shoot it and if it
doesn't happen you just have to keep on
going you know but um but to find to
have a project that has four or five or
three even three or four moments like
that that you feel are going to be that
the the high points of the film and then
make sure they'll stay you stay true to
those no matter what then I think if
it'll work you know as long as
everything's sort of built around that
kind of like an action movie you know
you but you not that you should build an
action movie round action sequences but
if you find the you know you want to
make you want to make sure those moments
are there and I think co she has a few
of those that there where there's like a
spin on a certain character or a moment
something unexpected and those are the
ones I always wanted to build the movie
around
you